hello
hello
hi
hi
you're wrong you have a question for us
i just wanted to make a few comments
just to share my perspective okay um i
coach women
part time and
it's a disaster but not only is it a
disaster from their side it's also the
quality of men and women has gone down
drastically
and i think the
they're promoting
you know being overweight is healthy
um
it's like i don't know what's going on
exactly but people have bought some kind
of kool-aid that's
out in the media
and you're correct for being
straight up with them but people don't
really want to hear
does that make sense
they don't want to know the truth
well we know that people like to have a
victim mindset when it comes to life
it's everybody else's fault with their
own right like i'm i'm fat because of
whatever right like it's like you're
like i can't do anything about it
because i'm big boned or they'll come up
with something right they have a thyroid
imbalance or something like that no just
move more eat like eat better it's not
complicated so
um you know people want to
hit like the fringes like we see all
this
it's everywhere on internet today on
twitter like everywhere it's like i
stand with whatever's trending
this flag that rainbow this butterfly
that
and then you have biological men with
their junk still competing with women
and swimming right and it's like
am i the only one that looks at this and
goes this is nuts so yeah things are a
little weird out there it's not like you
know you're preaching anybody that's
never heard it before you're preaching
to the choir um did you have a question
too or was it just kind of like a share
because you're dealing with so what kind
of women do you coach like do you coach
them for dating like is it life coaching
what do you do exactly
it's mostly through narcissistic abuse
recovery basically and so sure you're
you're basically traumatized after that
but even the people
look a lot of people carry trauma you
know even if it's minute they carry it
with them in those relationships and red
flags is actually what i teach because i
feel like if you know red flags you're
just not going to get burned
but the thing is that no one human just
has one red flag
they usually have tons of red flags and
you're either going to see them right
away or it's going to take a little bit
of time and you're going to see them so
the point is
when these guys or the females when they
see red flags like if you see one
realistically it should be a deal
breaker
that's it it's like what's an example of
a red flag
what's the common one that you see
um you can tell the manipulation so a
lot of times let's say if they have some
type of plan uh plans for a date the
woman will change it
she'll change it
um
and then if he goes along with it
in my opinion
she's already stating how the
relationship's going to go down and if
he doesn't stop it right away she's
going to lead that relationship you know
what's funny about that yeah
if if i were to say that exact same
thing in a video on my channel
the woke feminist mob would come in and
just [ __ ] destroy it
because i'm a do telling other dudes at
but what a woman says that you know what
let's go clip this one let's see what we
get out of this
i have a clips channel so i'm gonna i'm
gonna see what happens with this this
little bit here but richard can i say
something yeah go ahead
uh so they would destroy you but they do
destroy me too oh yeah so i do have
um i haven't been on it lately because i
had a and someone close to me passed
away um so i took a little break however
when i have posted certain videos they
come after me
okay
and they don't understand
really what valuing yourself respecting
yourself means they don't understand
that and they think being half naked
twerking
whatever else the hell that they do they
think that that actually means that they
are empowered and i'm like sis you have
no clue what being empowered is and it's
definitely not that how old are you
interested
at 47. okay so i mean like you've seen a
lot i've seen a lot
you've been doing this for a while
uh fairly new at it
let me ask you a question i haven't
noticed a trend where
women under about 28 30 like late like
late 20s 30s where they're self-aware
about this like you could have this
conversation with a 23 year old you
think she'd hear it
maybe maybe 10 percent right very few it
just really depends on the parents so
the
people are just having babies and um
emotionally unstable people
keep having children that's the root
cause
right yeah the
the dumb people are out [ __ ] the
smart people there's no question
i'm pretty sure that joe rogan's got a
joke about that somewhere
uh-huh yeah so i mean i have a lot to
say about it but
the problem though too that i've heard
from men their perspective is that women
in that age group they'll they'll be
going on dates and the girl will be
taking
selfies without him but like at the
restaurant maybe it's got a cool
background yeah red flag it's an
absolutely no it's like you know put
down your phone we're on a date and if
you can't do that you just leave
just pay for your [ __ ] and leave and
just get up and walk away have some
[ __ ] dignity guys like you know why
do you tolerate that nonsense
why do they yeah because they don't have
better options that's why you know to
your earlier point where you're saying
you know both men and women are failing
today men are weak soft soy i mean
there's men walking around with female
breast tissue right like it's like men
are not men anymore so that's why when
i'm talking these guys and i'm like dude
lift weights go learn how to make money
be captivating you know have interesting
hobbies sort of thing like if you can
just do that you're basically in the top
10 of men that's it that's like
like take a shower you know clean your
dick when you you know when you're in
the shower right you're right basically
smell good smell good when you walk by
she will notice you be competent you
know know where you're going if you get
a flat tire know how to change it right
basic stuff so attractive and then when
that lady called in though also that
i don't know i wasn't vibing with her
with her tone she's taking too long i
know i'm being critical but i'm getting
to a point
she's talking about like the woman's
gonna help her man but then that doesn't
necessarily make him alpha that doesn't
necessarily make me then look up to him
and be
amazed by him
do you know what i'm saying yep do you
guys have anything for anastasia before
we move on i've got a couple on that
last point one thing i've noticed of
american girls because i was in new york
for about a week i'm back in mexico and
you notice the culture differences
immediately just getting on and off the
airplane i noticed like especially like
more of those like liberal kind of
coastal type cities the women will do
things like that but she kind of looks
around like look at me like i'm doing
what a woman should do and as a guy i
can feel it's disingenuous so that's one
thing
going back to your point about the girl
trying to change the date a lot of a lot
of them do that and a lot of guys in the
space will say oh that's a [ __ ] test but
for me that's a leading indicator of
what she's of where she's trying to put
you on her roster so you very have to
very early you have to completely
steamroll over that thing or if she
insists do something like hey you know
what you knew the plan let me know when
you're actually free and then usually
you'll never hear back or she'll drop it
immediately in that moment and then
everything's smooth sailing from there
you know what's interesting like a lot
of guys today would say something like
all right fine i'll do thursday instead
of tuesday but you're buying drinks now
right and you know when you do that a
lot of the women especially younger ones
when they have a lot of options they're
like no no no they'll just you know like
kind of move on past it right so they
don't like nobody's holding these women
accountable that are behaving badly
because men don't know how to do it
anymore is what the problem is
and a lot of times i'll
i'll see that they they don't
demonstrate good behavior until like
there's been like a series of things
like a series of dates or hookups or
outings or whatever and then when they
start to get into like more of that
relational frame then they'll start
stepping up and then and then
demonstrating those good behaviors but
again if you look at the leading
indicators like early in the
conversation save your conversations and
do this you'll know initially where she
was trying to put you and that's
probably where she's going to try to
position you even you know once the veil
gets dropped after she gets what she
wants which in this scenario would be
the uh uh the commitment yeah um
anastasia um
yeah to your earlier point um you know
i'm from europe originally and you know
what what i see here and i've i've
railed to the guy several times about it
i said most guys are looking forward to
the upcoming weekend and they're going
to consume tons of cheap beer and crap
food and yell at sports on tv and that's
it they off they're not putting any
additional value into their lives and
none of that's attractive to women
um so i am um
i was born in america but my background
is greek so yes i feel like
pure pure pure americans especially like
women i do see a trend i actually say
things that rub a lot of women the wrong
way because i feel like american women
care more about their nails than they do
about their weight their skin their
mindset you know what i mean and their
money so they'll be literally morbidly
obese walking around but their nails are
just on point but not european women
they care about their skin they like to
when they leave their house they look
nice they're put together and i feel
like american women
slobs i mean that's uggs
that's still a part of like european
culture though right like
american culture is still quite a bit
different than you know european even
for a woman like you that's
born in america but greek i mean your
yaya would have basically instilled
um values and
certain like you know feminine behaviors
in you from a child right because of the
old sort of country sort of thing so a
lot of it has to do with like nature
nurture sort of stuff too
anastasia who's your typical client like
what age range
i would honestly say around late 30s
early 40s but i do i do have 20 i do
have 20 something year olds and they
tolerate a lot
they tolerate a lot the 20 something
year olds what do they tolerate
a lot of horrible behavior
can you give us an example for example i
don't know maybe that's what you call
the plate i'm not really sure what the
plate means i just found you recently
but i like your vibe i like your
perspective
um
meaning like he doesn't want to be
exclusive with her or what
it's not that i i can i can see red
flags
miles away and because of what i've been
through also i feel like i can smell
uh like a like a control freak and i
feel like men also even when you guys
are
even before your date realistically if
you pay attention you can even see from
the banter on text or if it's on a
dating website or something you can tell
kind of where it's going to go you can
see if she has vitality if she's
interesting
um if it's only there's energy or
emotion in the conversation and it goes
up and down and you can kind of predict
where it's going
i'm trying to drill down because we're
not getting to the point here i'm trying
to ask when you say you see like red
flags i need like i'm looking for like a
concrete example so like what are these
20 something women
putting up with by i don't know these
are these generally younger men they're
dating or these older men that they're
dating and and what exactly are we
talking about here like what's night
what is an example of a red flag and
then why is that a red flag
they're usually the same age they
already have shown
behaviors of you know talking poorly to
them um
you know standing them up for like a
date
um
[Music]
which what else
like making them pay for something i
just think that that's
why would you make that person pay it
depends what you're looking for you guys
have been told for years now that men
and women are equal right and that and
it's such a [ __ ] yeah well that's
what they've been told right i mean like
you know like a guy like me if you're on
a date you know the card goes down it's
always gonna work it's it's made out of
gold or platinum or some [ __ ] like that
and she doesn't have to pay for anything
right that's the way that most guys roll
that are put together that are high
value but when you get these kids that
are hearing all their lives like men and
women are equal you know women have like
hit the pay gap and you have to [ __ ]
it's like okay so they start thinking
well i'll buy my drink and she'll buy
her drink and that's the way it's
supposed to be right
it's weird they're actually expecting
the women now to take care of them like
as a first date but if that makes sense
you want to know something that's really
funny anastasia this all comes from
toxic feminism this is all like the
narrative i agree that women have been
like blurting about like you know we're
equal you know we're the same and
clearly we're not because when you put a
biological male in a woman's swimming
competition he destroys them in the
men's category he's like rank 400
right men and women are not the same
right so they're not they're not the
same and those women though those women
i'm sorry to interrupt you that promote
that
just so you know deep down
their feeling is
look how worthy i am and i'm going to
show you
that's all your clients
uh no i'll tell you what it is no not
those girls it's it's these toxic
feminists actually hate pretty girls
right because they don't look anything
like them like as long as you're
overweight and you embrace your fat
acceptance then you're part of their
club but if you don't and you know you
look good in a bikini then they shame
them they say oh that's objectifying
women that's objectifying women but
putting a fat test holiday on the cover
of cosmopolitan she looks like a
freaking sausage right like the clothing
is so tight you can see everything
it's true and even
i put myself together and i usually like
i have you know some makeup on and i'm
put together you want to know how we fix
this anastasia
oh you're not going to like it but all
the girls got to get together and march
on parliament hill and start you know
asking for masculine men and feminine
women it's going to start with a whole
bunch of law changes that aren't going
to serve the female primary social order
like family law for example right
we just lost her oh she's still there no
we lost no i'm here i'm here it's 50. we
lost 50. yeah so like it's got to start
with something like that because guys
guys can't enact any kind of change in
this right
that's really the long-term solution
that's how it gets fixed i just wanted
to ask one other question what
in what way are you helping these women
reconcile at 38 39 40 that the men that
they generally are
going after are not going after them and
they don't want them essentially
do you mind repeating that i don't know
if i understand that
so
generally women that are
38 39 40 that are reaching that age
a common thing that they're being told
is go get your degrees go make your
money go be the ceo and then once you do
that and you're successful and you've
reached the pinnacle there's going to be
a line of high value rich handsome men
that are going to be looking to get out
on one knee and that's
typically not the case that's a lie how
much how much are you seeing that and
how are you helping with that how are
you helping these women reconcile that
i'm actually very real with them and you
know you i only attract a certain type
of client as well because i'm not going
to sugarcoat things and it doesn't it
doesn't feel good but as long as if you
can get through that point and you can
accept it you know what i mean you can
get to the other side and it is much
prettier than this side but a lot of
women at that age just so you know they
either become desperate
and then they end up with like a beta
male
unhappy et cetera fill in the blank
or a lot of them then feel like they've
wasted their life on that they don't
have eggs anymore they're trying to
freeze their eggs
and they go through this process of it's
almost like um
you're mourning that time that you lost
it's really it happens with a lot of
women between 40 and 50 like where did
the time go what have i really
accomplished like because here i am
alone you know what are they usually
wasting time in your experience
um
you know trying to get their degrees and
an extra degree at their job also um
you know the the time in the bars and
the girls trips and all of that stuff
there it is
yeah so the parties and the degrees yeah
yeah the parties and the degrees yeah
look
i've been saying this for years ladies
you know
if you're to listen to us in your 20s
you wouldn't have these problems in your
30s and 40s
it's sad because then they think that
the handsome
you know stud that's got it going on is
going to go for them and they want
nothing
to do with them they want the younger
hotter tighter fresher version they
don't want some like used up 40 year old
with three degrees we don't care about
your degrees ladies we can't do anything
with them
and the and conversely the younger
hotter girls want guys that have their s
together that lean more into the
masculine type category so like i've
always noticed like feminism is kind of
an s test for women too like you never
meet a hot girl that has those beliefs
in her head like she might loosely have
them because the professor spouted them
off one time but like no women that are
decent that have decent smv actually
believe those things and ones that do
like when they meet a guy like me or
like moth for like rich they let go of
it pretty quickly because there's like
it's just not happening that does not
fly in my household mm-hmm
yeah all right well um we gotta start to
wrap it up so um i'm gonna let you go
okay
okay thanks for hopping in and sharing
your uh thoughts hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you